[موسيقى]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير نحييكم الى
بانوراما سنتابع فيها او في بدايتها الحدث
لهذا اليوم طبعا مع تحقيق ترامب ولكن
لدينا كذلك موضوع ثاني وهذه هي عناوين
ملفاتنا
وفي النقاش الاول ترامب في اخطر مواجهه مع
القضاء هل ستعرقل قضيه الوثائق المسربه
طريقه الى البيت الابيض ام ستزيد من
شعبيتك
وفي ملفنا الثاني روسيا تقر بتباعد مواقف
سوريا وتركيا بحاجتها الى عمل شاق هل
ستنجح مسوده طريقي او خريطه الطريق في
تقريب العلقه بينهما
ونحييكم الى نقاش الملف الاول في اجواء
مشحونه بالترقب يظهر الرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب امام المحكمه في
ميامي بولايه فلوريدا لواجهاتهم جنائيه
غير مسبوقه تاريخيا ضد رئيس سابق في البيت
الابيض ترامب متهم باستحواذه غير القانوني
على وثائق السريه بعد انتهاء ولايتها
الرئاسيه واسعيه الى عرقله الجهود
الحكوميه لاستعادتها وستكون هذه المره
الثانيه التي يمثل فيها ترامب خلال اشهر
لواجهاتها مان جنائيه ولكن هذه المره
الدعوه ترفعها وزاره العدل على عكس قضيه
نيويورك وربما تكمن الخطوره بافاده
المدعين العاملين التي رات ان ترامب عرض
الامن القومي للخطر ما يعني ان ترامب قد
يواجه عقوبه سجن كبيره في حاله الادانه
لكن ترامب الذي سيكمل عمه 77 الاربعاء صعد
من خطابه
المدعي الفيدرالي بقضيه ترامب
خبير قضايا فساد وجرائم حرب
امضى سنوات عده في وزاره العدل الامريكيه
ومؤخرا في بعض المحاكم الدوليه
في عام 2018 عين سميث رئيسا للادعاء في
المحكمه الخاصه بكوسوفو
في نوفمبر من عام 2022 وبعيد اعلان ترامب
ترشحه لسباق البيت الابيض عين جاكس مثل
الاشراف على تحقيقين مستقلين
جنائيه معتبرا انه احتفظ جنائيا بسجلات
سريه بعد انتهاء ولايته وانه تامر لعرقله
التحقيق
لم يكشف مكتب سميث بعد عن التهم المتعلقه
بالتحقيق الثاني حول دور ترامب في اقتحام
انصاره للكابتن عام 2021
اولى تصريحاته في قضيه ترامب القوانين
التي تحمي معلومات الدفاع القومي ضروريه
لسلامه وامن الولايات المتحده ويجب
انفاذها
حلفاء ترامب يستمتون في الدفاع عنه
ويستنكرون ما سموها ملاحقات سياسيه
محاميته اكدت ان الترامب كل الحق في
الاحتفاظ بوثائق بعد ان رفعت عنها السريه
ان ابو الجمهوري جيم جوردن كرر ان
المحاكمه من تدبير معسكر الرئيس
الديمقراطي جو بايدن رغم ان لائحه الاتهام
تبنت هيئه محلفين كبرى من المواطنين في
فلوريدا رئيس بلديه ميامي الجمهور فرانسيس
عبر عن امله في ان تمر الامور بسلام
النائب عن الوزيان كلاري هيجنز طلب من
انصاره ربط حزام الامان للانطلاق اما اندي
بيكس من ولايه اريزنا فقد غرد قائلا لقد
وصلنا الان الى مرحله الحرب العين بالعين
[موسيقى]
نناقش هذا الملف مع ضيوفنا من واشنطن
دكتور وليد فارس الخبير في السياسه
الخارجيه الامريكيه ومن واشنطن الدكتور
حنا حنانيه ممثل الحزب الديمقراطي في
ولايه فرجينيا اهلا بكم ضيوفي الكرام
لمناقشه هذا الملف ولكن قبل البدء
بالاسئله والنقاش لنتوقف مع اخر التطورات
من امامي المحكمه الفيدراليه في ميامي
زميلنا حسين الطوط مراسل العربيه من هناك
حسين اهلا بك معنا كيف يبدو المشهد اتابع
من ورائك حضور اعلامي كبير وهذا الفناه
تعودنا به مع محاكمه راب مثلا التي شفناها
من شهرين ولكن هذه المره تختلف الوضع اكبر
اثقل واصعب كذلك كيف هي صوره حسين
تحيه لك ريم بالفعل كما وصفتي انت الوضع
اثقل واصعب واكبر ولهذا نرى حشود جمهوريه
هنا في ميامي فلوريدا هي ولايه تميل الى
الجمهوريين لذلك هناك عدد كبير من انصاره
على عكس ما شاهدناه منذ شهرين امام
المحكمه في نيويورك هنا الجمهوريون حضروا
بقوه طبعا ايضا كان هناك حضور امني ازدادت
كثافته مع ازدياد عدد المناصرين الذين
يتظاهروا هنا البارحه كان هناك مؤتمر
صحفيا قالت الشرطه بانها لن تضع او تضع
حواجز حديديه وهذا ما لاحظنا نحن الان في
محيط المحكمه لم تمنع الشرطه من الاقتراب
منها وضعت لاصق اصفر لتبعد ناس قليلا عن
جدار المحكمه ولكن تركت لهم الحريه بان
يتصرفوا ان يتظاهروا وان يكون هناك
احتفالات صغيره هذا صح التعبير في اكثر من
مكان هناك ما قلنا الع
المناصرين لتراب اكثر من المنتقدين له كما
نلاحظ هنا امام هذه المحكمه حسين خلينا
نفهم منك كيف يتابع مناصر ترامب ما يحدث
هل هناك قناعه بان هذا الموضوع وهذا الملف
هو خطير للغايه وهي سابقه في تاريخ
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ام لا زال
هناك تشبث بمقوله بان هذا الملف السياسي
وهناك محاوله للتجني على ترامب
نضع الخط نقطع الخط قطع الخط نحن نسمعك يا
حسين لكن انت لا تسمعنا سنعود لك الاكيد
باننا سنبقى في متابعه هذا الموضوع ولكن
في نشرتنا القادمه
[موسيقى]
نتابع هذا الموضوع واعود من جديد لترحيب
بضيوفي من واشنطن الدكتور وليد فارس
الخبير في سياسه الخارجيه الامريكيه من
واشنطن دائما
ممثل الحزب الديمقراطي في ولايه فرجينيا
اهلا بكم ضيوفي الكرام واسمحوا لي ان ابدا
مع الدكتور فارس دكتور فارس
نتفق قلنا بانه هذا الملف هو سابقا في
تاريخ الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وقد
يكون الملف الاثقل في مسيره ترامب ولكن
يقول البعض بان ترامب فعلا بنفسه ما لم
يفعله اعداؤه به هل تتفق مع هذه المقوله
لا اتحدث فقط على احتفاضه بالوثائق ولكن
اتحدث على التسجيل الذي تفاخر فيه
باحتفاضه بهذه الوثائق اتحدث عن امتناعه
كما يقول الادعاء العام على تسليم هذه
الوثائق على مغالطته قال بانه سلمتها وهو
لم يسلمها كلها ما الذي فعله ترامب بنفسه
اولا اتفق على النقاط الثلاث ولكن ساشرح
النقطه الاولى انها اخطر محاكمه بتاريخ
الولايات المتحده تقريبا صحيح منذ عشرات
وعشرات السنين هذا لم يحصل النقطه الثانيه
ان المساله تتعلق يعني بموضوع جرمي ثبت
هذا الموضوع باخطر معاقبه قد تاتي هذا
ايضا صحيح ولكن هذا مبني على الايذاء يعني
اذا اثر في المحاكمه والمحاكمه ستكون
طويله جدا وقد تكلمتم الان في التقرير عن
يعني عده امور اهمها بالنسبه هي القاضيه
القاضيه بامكانها ان اتصرف بموضوع الزمن
ونحن نعرف ان المعركه اساسا هي حول منعه
من ان يستكمل اجراءات ترشيحه او حملته ولا
يترشح وهذا هو بتقدير انا الجبهه السياسيه
اذا هنالك ثلاثه امور انظر اليها الامر
الاول هو المعركه الاعلاميه حول الموضوع
لقد كنت على وسائل
[موسيقى]
مجموعه كبيره من انصار ترامب تحاول تقول
ان المحاكمه السياسيه
تطلعي رايي نشر قبل كم يوم بكون حوالي 50%
من الشعب الامريكي
ولكن من هنالك معلومات شبه مؤكده ومعلومات
التي تظهر ان ترامب قد قام باخذ الوسائط
وان الوسائط موجوده في منتجعه
كما حصل مع هي كانت هنالك محاكمه وهو من
المهم جدا ان ياخذوا قضاء مجراه بالنسبه
للتراب طبعا ان يعملها محاكمه سياسيه وان
يعملها موضوع كبير بالاعلام سوف يساعده في
حملته الانتخابيه ما اسلف صديق فقط
ولكن لم تتحدث
عن لم تتحدث عن الديمقراطيين اعلم بانه
حضرتك ممثل عن حزب الديمقراطي ولكن
الامريكيون يقولون بانهم كذلك يجب ان يفتح
تحقيق بحقهم لانه ما فعله ترامب الان
فعلوه كذلك في مقابر حتى وان كانت هناك
صحيح اختلافات جزئيه في الموضوع
اختلافات اختلافات عندي بس بالاول خليني
اوضح انا كنت ممثل عن الحزب الديمقراطي في
مؤتمر الحزب وليس متحدث باسم الحزب
الديمقراطي ولكن ممثل في مؤتمر الحزب في
ولايه فلجينيا
هنالك عده امور يقوم القضاء بتحقيق فيها
حتى في الوقت الحالي مع ابن بايدن وعده
امور اخرى ولكن كما حصل مع ترامب ان هذه
الوثائق قد تم اخذها وكما التباهي بوجودها
منع المحققين من اجل استعادتها لم يحصل في
تاريخ الولايات المتحده هنالك حادثه حدثت
قريبه منها ولكن في النهايه الرئيس
الى
المسؤولين عنها ولكن في هذه الحاله يكون
الرئيس بالتباهي بها الرئيس ترامب من يوم
استلم الحكم حتى من قبل ذلك لا يوجد ضوابط
تحكمه حيث يقوم بكل ما يريد ان يفعله ويظن
انه بامكانه ان يفعل اي شيء حتى انه لم
يعترف بنتائج الانتخابات وهي سابقه لم
تحصل طريق الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وهنالك عده اموريه لا يلت بالقوانين
الرئيس ترامب وسوف نرى ماذا يحصل في
العداله وكيف العداله سوف تاخذ مجراها انا
مؤمن جدا في العداله في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ولكن هذه القضيه البعد السياسي
لها اصبح اهم من البعد القضائي لان كما
اسلف صديق وليد فارس سوف تاخذ فتره حتى
تتم المحاكمه وخصوصا مع وجود القاضيه التي
تعتبرتيتها بحيث يناسب الرئيس ترامب في
حملته الانتخابيه دكتور وليد لو نصحح بعض
المعلومات
او بعضنا
بعض توجيه الاتهامات تم تحقيق معه حكم لا
شيء يمنعه من الترشح اما على مستوى الحزب
او كذلك على مستوى الرئاسه في 2020 هذا
متفقين فيه ولكن على المستوى الحزبي
والشعبي ان ثبتت هذه الاتهامات كيف ستكون
صورته حزبيا وشعبيا
لو سمحت لي ان ارجع الى الوراء سنتيمتر
واحد صحيح
اذا يعني ذهب الى المحكمه وكانت هنالك
الاتهامات وحكم حتى هذه اللحظه حكم يعني
بدات المحاكمات وكما قال الزميل قد تاخذ
وقتا طويلا هذا لن يمنعه قانونا من ان
يستمر في ترشيحه في حاله وحده استثنائيه
اذا صدر حكم جرمي بحقه قبل الانتخابات هذا
قد يكون له وقع مختلف جدا وهذا تدرسه
المراجع الدستوريه والقانونيه في احتمال
ان يمنع ولكن هذا المنع يجب ان يذهب عبر
الحزب الجمهوري وهذا يعيدنا الى الى
السؤال الاهم التي طرحته
انا بتقديري وانا متفاجئ من استراتيجيه
وزاره العدل قليلا اذا كان الهدف منعه من
الوصول اما اذا كان الهدف ان يحاكم بانه
ارتكب ما يسمى هذا امر اخر لانه ما يجري
الان انه الخصم الحقيقي لا ترامب ليس وليس
الاخرين يعني لا يتعدون واحد الى اثنين
الى ثلاثه بالمئه وربما يوم الانتخابات
سيكون اقل من ذلك هو حاكم ولايه فلوريدا
ليس لانه له او اصوات اكثر ولكنه هو
الحاجز المانع يعني ترامب معروف له 80% من
الحزب الجمهوري تقريبا سوف يكون هو المرشح
ولكن على الصعيد الانتخابات الوطنيه اذا
لم تصوت كتله الذي يحوز على 38 او شيء من
هذا النوع فلن يربح الانتخابات الوطنيه
اذا المعركه الاهم هي بين انصار ديس
وانصار ترامب وردنا على سؤالك هذا قد يؤثر
الا اذا تمكنت ترامب من ان
تطهر نفسه للقاعده الجمهوريه انه مغبون
انه الضحيه لهذا نرى لذلك نرى انه يتكلم
وانا بريء ولماذا كل هذا ليربح المعركه
الداخليه في الح
[__] وهذه تصريحاته
حتى انه وصف المدعي العام بالمختل العقلي
تصريحات ترامب نحن نتابعها في الواقع ولم
يعد احد فينا يتفاجا من استخدامه مثل هذه
المصطلحات ولكن دكتور حنا هل هذه فرصه
للديمقراطيين هل هذه فرصه قادرون على
اقتناصها وكيف يمكن ان يستفيد
الديمقراطيون من مثل هكذا اتهامات
او ممكن ان يستفيد الديمقراطيين
بالمستقلين كما نعلم اليوم الكتله
الانتخابيه الاكبر في الولايات المتحده هي
المستقلين لم تعد الديمقراطيين ولا
الجمهوريين وان كان هنالك عدد اكبر من
الديمقراطيين مسجلين ولكن المستقلين هم من
سوف يحزنوا الانتخابات الرئاسيه في حاله
كان المرشح ترامب وفي حاله كان هنالك
زي شبه اجماع على انه قاموا بعمل اجرامي
ممكن جدا ان يكون نسبه كبيره من المستقلين
بان تصوت ضد ترامب وهنا قد يكون للتصويت
ضد ترامب اكثر مما هو مع بايدن بالنسبه
للمستقلين في حاله لم يكن المرشح النهائي
للحزب الديمقراطي ترامب بسبب هذه الاسره
وكان مثل المرشحه حاكم ولايه فلوريدا ممكن
جدا ان تكون نسبه التصويت من داعمين
ترامبو داعمين يدعمون ترامب بشكل كبير جدا
وبالنسبه اليهم يعني اصبحت شبه تالي ترامب
ممكن جدا ان يكون مجموعه منهم بعدم
التصويت في الانتخابات العامه وذلك
احتجاجا ان ترام هو مرشحهم فمن الممكن جدا
ان لم يربح ترامب الترشيح الحزبي الجمهوري
ان يدعي كما ادعى في السابق ان الانتخابات
كانت مزوره ونسبه كبيره من مصوتي لا يشارك
في الانتخابات العامه نحن دائما نتحدث عن
فرضيات ان ستكون هناك تهم جنائيه اجراميه
ولكن دكتور فارس لنعود قليلا الى تفاصيل
هذه الاتهامات طيب لسائل ان يسال لماذا
يحتفظ بمعلومات خاصه بالامن الامريكي
بمعلومات خاصه بتمركز قوات عسكريه
او قواعد قادره ان تكون جاهزه في توقيت ما
في نقطه ما عندما تستهدف الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه كذلك النووي الامريكي هناك
ملفات حساسه جدا لماذا ترامب يحتفظ بها
وخاصه وان طلب منه ارجاعها ارجع جزءا منها
ولكن احتفظ بالبقيه وتفاخر بالاحتفاظ بها
سؤال مطروح ما الذي كان ينويه بفعل ذلك
سؤال كبير وهو مطروح يعني بكل الكره
الارضيه تقريبا الان عده نقاط النقطه
الاولى
واهمها في المحكمه وليس في الراي العام هي
ما يسمى النيه الجرنيه هذه اهم شيء يعني
اذا اثبت انه هو اخذ هذه الملفات اولا
خلصتا لم يعلن عنها
ووضعها في مكتبه ولم يعرف بها حتى
الحرس لا ننسى انه هو لا يزال تحت المظله
الفيدراليه من يحمي مررنابه ومن يهتم
بوثائق من الخارج على الاقل وليس من
الداخل اذا كان هذا غيره اذا كان هذا
واردا واكثر من ذلك انا باعتقادي هذا سوف
تكون خطه المحامين الدفاع اذا كان قد قام
بعمل جيرمي يعني ارسلها الى طرف اخر الى
دول حليفه الى دول صديقه الاصدقاء سياسيين
واكثر من ذلك اذا قبض ثمنها بالعمله ولا
اعتقد طبعا هذا وارد اذا كل هذا كان مثبت
بالطبع هو قد قام بعمل
في المستقبل وليس الان ولكن اخطا واعطى
الادعاء يعني
مواقع كبيره للهجوم عليه
يكلفه كثير دكتور فارس سيكلفه الكثير
والكثير ولكن قد لا يكلفه ما نعتقده في
الوقت الحالي البعض يقول دكتور حنا بانه
كل هذا قد ينقلب لصالح ترامب حضرتك تعلم
بانه لترامب كاريزما معينه وقادر ان يقلب
المواضيع باتجاهه لمصلحته فهل هو قادر على
ذلك هل شعبيا قادر ان يلتف او ان يلف حول
الجماهير الشعبيه
حتى الان قادر يعني في الحقيقه حتى الان
استطاع ان يجعل هذه الملفات سواء هذه او
المحكمه السابقه
تفضل دكتور حنا فقط لانه حضرتك تتحدث هناك
صور نتابعها لموكب ترامب الان فعلا سيبدا
بالتحرك ترامب الذي وصل بالامس الى
فلوريدا الان يغادر منزله او منتجعه
ويتوجه الى المحكمه في ميامي نعلم بانه
ترامب كان حكم منذ شهرين في نيويورك ولكن
الان هذه المحاكمات تتم في ميامي والان
موقف ترامب يغادر منتجعه في طريقه الى مقر
المحكمه فيما يامي كما نتابع على الشاشه
بدات في الواقع جموع المؤيدين في محيط
المحكمه وهذا ما سنبقى في متابعته لمتابع
كل هذه التفاصيل لحظه بلحظه مشاهدينا
اذا هذه هي الصور التي نتابعها وسنبقى في
انتظار بدء خروج موكب ترامب نحن تبعنا
صوره او فيديو لسياره شرطه ولكن سنبقى في
متابعه هذه الصور كذلك دكتور حنان تعلم
حضرتك بان هناك متابعه جماهيريه اعلاميه
خاصه نحن رصدناها في محيط محكمه ميامي
وكنت احدث حضرتك على قدره ترامب على
امكانيه قلب الموازين باتجاهه لفائدته وهل
تخدمه مثل هكذا تصريحات ربما احيانا تاتي
من الديمقراطيين لتهامه بعدم المسؤوليه
بتجاوزه لبعض
الاطر او الخطوط الحمراء وحضرتك تعلم بانه
في الحاسبه الديمقراطي هناك كذلك من هو
متهم بنفس هذا الشيء فالى اي مدى قادر
ترامب ان ينجح في قلب الموازين ليجند
لمصلحته
في المدى قصير انا براينا سوف ينجح ترامب
في قلب وزين لمصلحته وحتى الان قد نجح في
ذلك فعندما نقول ان 50% من الشعب الامريكي
يقتنع انه محاكمه سياسيه هذه النسبه عاليه
جدا ولن يستطيع احد ان يفعلها شخص متمرد
جدا في الدعايه وفي الاعلام
يعتبر الناس متمرسين جدا والذين استطاعوا
بالسابق ان يقلبوا الامور ومن الممكن جدا
ان يفعلها مره اخرى ولكن هذا في المدى
القريب في المدى البعيد عندما تتوضح
الامور اكثر من المؤكد ان الشعب الامريكي
سوف ينظر اليها بنظره مختلفه
الدكتور وليد فارس وكما سمعنا بالنسبه لما
حصل هذه المره ما حصل كان واضحا فلا احد
ينكر انه قام باخذ ملفات سريه ولا احد
ينكر انه قام باطلاع بعض الاشخاص عليها
لان هي الاجراميه كانت موجوده او لا ذات
شيء اخر ولكن من المؤكد انه قام ببعض
الامور التي ممنوع ان يفعلها وايضا لا
يهمه
فاخر بانه قام بهذه الامور فهذه الامور
سوف سوف تؤثر بشكل سلبي في نهايه المطاف
خصوصا مع المستقلين في المجتمع الامريكي
دكتور فارس منذ قليل تحدثت حضرتك عن هذه
الاتهامات ولكن كذلك تحدثت عن اتهامات
اخرى نحن سنكون امامها نتحدث عن يعني
اتهامات متعلقه بدعوه مسؤوليه الانتخابات
في ولايه جورجيا بتغيير نتائج الانتخابات
2020 كذلك هناك تحقيقات ستفتح بشان دوره
في هجمات السادس من يناير من سنه 2021 على
مبنى الكابيتال بهدف عرقله التصويت على
فوز الرئيس جو بايدن في هذا الاطار هل
هناك محاوله
لفرز تتبعات على ترامب لافشاله تماما لانه
كنا نتحدث عن قضيه اخلاقيه منذ شهرين
اليوم نحن نتابع قضيه جديده تخص الامن
القومي ولكن هناك كذلك تحقيقات اخرى قادمه
كيف سيخرج منها ترامب
لو سمحت لي انا اعود ايضا سم الى الوراء
ونعود وارد على هذا السؤال واوضح قدر
المستطاع اولا فيما يتعلق بنقل يعني وثائق
سريه
ليس الاول
وواضح جدا من الاعلام ان الرئيس اوباما قد
اخذ معه ولكن بعد ان اعلم بالطبع جهاز
الوثائق الرسمي وله اليات معينه اخذ اكثر
من مليون ورقه هو قال ان معظمها كانت سوف
تكون لمكتبته وبعدها لكتبه الى اماكن ما
هنالك وعندما اتت السلطات الى مكتبه حلت
العمليه بنوع من حوار اداري او من اجراءات
اداريه بين مكتب الرئيس اوباما سابق رئيس
اوباما
الدكتور فارس اسمحلي فقط ان اتفاعل مع
حضرتك اوباما قال تحدث عن هذه
عن هذه المطالب او عن نيته ولكن يقال بان
ترامب غالط ترامب المشكله بانه لم يقل في
البدايه لانه بانه اخذ وثائق او ملفات
الان فعلا يتحرك موكب الرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب نحن نتابع هذه الصور ضيوفي
تفضلوا بالبقاء معي فقط للتعليق لبعض
اللحظات على هذا الصور الان يخرج ترامب من
منتجعه في طريقه الى مقر المحكمه في ميامي
وهذا ما نتابعه من خلال هذا الصور اذا
كالعاده ترامب في هذا الموكب يتجه الى
محكمه ميامي اولا ليستمع الى لائحه
الاتهامات بشكل
رسمي وكذلك فيما بعد الوقت لن يكون طويل
لسماع لائحه الاتهامات رغم اننا نتحدث عما
يقارب عن الاربعين اتهام وجه لترامب هذه
الاتهامات صنفها مراقبون على انها خطيره
جدا على انها حساسه وهي سابقه في تاريخ
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بان تكون هناك
اتهامات فيدراليه توجه لرئيس سابق في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه نحن نتحدث
مشاهدينا عن هذه الصور نتحدث عن موكب
للرئيس الامريكي
دونالد ترامب والذي يتوجه الى محكمه ميامي
ونتابع كذلك مجموعه اخرى من التفاصيل في
محيط المبنى هناك حضور اعلامي وهناك حضور
من مؤيدي الرئيس ترامب من المتوقع
مشاهدينا فيما يخص وصول ترامب وما الذي
سيحدث عند وصوله الى المحكمه بمجرد دخوله
المبنى سيتم وضع ترامب قيد الاعتقال كذلك
من المتوقع ان ياخذ نواب المرشلات بصمات
ترامب الكترونيا لكن ليس من المتوقع ان
ياخذوا صوره شخصيه للرئيس السابق هذا هو
موكب ترامب الى محكمه ميامي بعد ذلك
مشاهدينا
كذلك امام قاضي الصلح
لمحاكمته ومثوله الاولي من المفترض ان
يؤكد قاضيه تحقيق مع ترامب انه يفهم حقوقه
بموجب التعديل السادس بما في ذلك حقه في
محاكمه سريعه ومن المرجح كذلك كان يتنازل
محمد رامب عن القراءه الرسميه لي لائحه
الاتهام هناك حديث عن ان الرئيس سبق ترامب
من المتوقع ان يقدم اقرارا كذلك ببراءته
من جميع التهم السبعه وثلاثين وهي تهم
حساسه جدا وجهات لرئيس السابقات ترامب هذه
التهم تخص الامن القومي الامريكي
هو اولا اتهم
حفاظه او على محاوله ابقائه على ملفات جد
مهمه هذه الملفات تخص الامن القومي
الامريكي تخص التمركز العسكري في حاله
واجهت الولايات المتحده الامريكيه حرب او
هجوم عسكري هناك حديث كذلك في هذه الملفات
ومعلومات خاصه قلناها بالنووي الامريكي
هناك معلومات خاصه بدول اخرى
كالصين وايران وهذا هو الموكب الذي
يتواصل ونحن نتابعه دائما مشاهدينا هذا هو
موكب ترامب نذكر من جديد ببعض الاجراءات
المتوقعه حدوثها عند وصول الرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامبيلا المحكمه كذلك من المتوقع
ان يطلب المدعون الفيدراليون من قاضي
الصلح تقييد اتصالات ترامب باي شاهد محتمل
للحمايه طبعا كما يقال من العباس المحتمل
بالشهود ومن المرجح ان يتم الافراج عن
ترامب في انتظار المحاكمه بناء على تعهد
شخصي مشاهدينا ومتابعينا الاعتراف الشخصي
هو سند بدون تكلفه والذي لن يكون توفير
مالي يضمن الظهور في المستقبل بدلا من ذلك
يعود المتهم الى المحكمه لاجراءات
مستقبليه بالنسبه لجلسات الاستماع ستقعد
ستعقد عفوا هذه الجلسات في المستقبل امام
القاضيه ايلينكانا التي تم تكليفها
بالقضيه الج نائيه ونذكر بانه ايلين كانا
منذ ثلاث سنوات كانت ترامب هو الذي
نصبها وقتها منذ ثلاث سنوات وهي التي
ستكلف بهذه القضيه الجنائيه من الان
فصاعدا ويمكن تحديد موعد جلسه استماع
اوليه امام كانن خلال هذا الموثول الاولي
اذا مشاهدينا هذا هو موكب رئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب في طريقه
لمحكمه ميامي
وسنتابع دائما هذا الموضوع ابقوا معنا
لانه بعد قليل سنكون كذلك في متابعه لحظه
وصوله امام المحكمه ونحن نعلم بان الترام
بعض التفاصيل وبعض التصريحات كذلك
المنتظره كما فعل منذ شهرين عند محاكمته
الاولى في قضيه وصفت بالقضيه الاخلاقيه
بعد دفع اموال مقابل الصمت للممثله
الاباحيه ولكن هذه القضيه مشاهدينا يصنفها
البعض على انها القضيه الاكثر خطوره
والاكثر حساسيه دكتور فارس نحن نتابع هذا
الموقف موكب الرئيس ترامب مجموعه كبيره من
السيارات هناك في مقدمه هذا الموقف وفي
اخر هذا الموكب هناك كذلك تامين حتى وصوله
الى محيط هذه المحكمه ويبدو بان الموضوع
سياخذ جانبا من المتابعه ليس فقط
الاعلاميه التي كنت تحدثت عنها ولكن ستكون
هناك تداعيات سياسيه كبيره وكبيره جدا
لهذا الملف ما رايك
يعني لو سمحت لي انا اعود اكثر مره اخرى
لوضح النقطه واعود الى هذا الموضوع
بالنسبه للملفات لانه هذا امر رئيسي ليفهم
المشاهد وراي العام بشكل عام ويجب التمييز
بين هل اخذ ملفات الى مكان اخر من قبل
رئيس سابق هو الجرم او التصرف بها هو
الجرم الاجتهاد يقول التصرف بها وليس اخذ
الملفات لانه كل الرؤساء اخذوا ولكن
تصرفوا بها بشكل اهم او او اصح بالنسبه
للنتائج انا اعتقد ما يلي بالخلاصه حتى
الان
هل هذه الاليات كل هذه الدعاوى ستضعفه
ستجرحه سياسيا ولكنها لن تقتله سياسيا قبل
الانتخابات لماذا هنالك شيء في الثقافه
القانونيه الامريكيه تسمى سموكينجان يعني
المسدس الذي يعني نرى فيه الدخان اي الحجه
الدامغه الاساسيه التي من اجلها قد يسقط
قد يسقط حكما عليه من قبل المحلفين هذا
غير موجود يعني ليس هنالك من مكالمه مثلا
بين ترامبور رئيس دوله اخرى انا حصلت على
هذه الملفات وهذه هي مواقع
يعني المراكز الامريكيه هذا لم يحصل
وبالتالي
ولكن الذي سوف يزعج ترامب او يضعف ترامب
هو فعلا في نهايه المطاف الانتخابات
النهائيه وكل هذا البركان الذي ينفجر الان
سوف يحدد لتران قدرته ان يكون المرشح
الجمهوري حتى الان لا ارى حاجز امامه ولكن
كما قال الزميل هنالك مشكله في الانتخابات
النهائيه اذا تحرك الراي العام ضده في
الوسط اي في هذه هؤلاء الخمس الى العشر
ملايين ناقب الذين سوف يحكمون على هذه
الامور ونحن نتابع معك دكتور فارس ونستمع
طبعا لتحليلك ونحاول فهم تداعيات هذا
الموضوع وواقعه بكل تفاصيله نتابع كذلك
هذه المشاهد المباشره من العربيه مع هذا
الموكب ولكن كذلك نشير الى تعليق ترامب
ونحن نتحدث منذ قليل منذ دقائق قليله
ترامب يقول نحن في احد اكثر الايام حزنا
في تاريخ امريكا دكتور حنا ما رايك في هذا
الكلام هل هذا ينطبق كذلك على
الديمقراطيين هل تورث رئيس سابق في قضيه
حساسه كهذه تمس الرئاسه الامريكيه بشكل
عام ايا كان توجه الرئيس ديمقراطي جمهوري
ام ان هذا هذه الايام قد تكون اكثر الايام
فرحا بالنسبه للديمقراطيين
لا اود ان اقول انها فرحا او حتى انها
اكثر الايام حزنا حيث انها سابع من يناير
حصل الهجمات على الكابت هل تعتبر من اكثر
الايام حزنا في المجتمع الديمقراطي
الامريكي حيث في هذا اليوم تم التهجم على
صلح الديمقراطيه في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وهو حزم بكثير بكثير من اي حدث
تاني والحدث اليوم ليس بهذا الحدث الكبير
ولكن ترامب مشهور بانه يعرف اني يسخر
الامور لصالح خصوصا
هذه سابقه سيذكرها تاريخ في تاريخ
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه اول رئيس
يواجه توهم فيدراليه واتهم بهذا الشكل
ولكن يعني حصلتهم قبل شهر الماضي وهنالك
عده ملفات سوف تاتي وسوف تكون اكبر من هذا
حيث الملف بالنسبه للهجمات في السابع
مليونير سواء كانت عن طريق المحاكمه او عن
طريق عندما يحصل بين سبورت ترامب او بين
بعد لجمهوريين وترامب سوف يكون له تاثير
كبير جدا حيث ان الشارع الامريكي لم
يتعاطف مع ترامب بالنسبه لاحداث السابع من
يناير مازال الشارع الامريكي يشعر بالنقمه
بالنسبه لما حدث بالسابع من يناير وفي حال
كما وجود
مئه بالمئه هجوم على الكابيتال من قبل
مناصرين ترامب هذا الحدث انا برايي كان
الحدث اكيد اللي كان من احزن الايام في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وسوف تكون له
تباعدات كثيره في الانتخابات انا برايي
اكثر من تداعيات ما يحصل اليوم عندما ياتي
هذا الملف الى العالم سواء كان عن طريق
المحاكمه او عن طريق الذي سوف يحصل بين
الجمهوريين في خصوصا كان النائب ترامب
عندما يفتح الملف بين هدايا الاثنين من
الممكن زهور معلومات جديده كثيره قد تؤثر
بشكل كبير
دكتور فارس هل تتفق مع الدكتور حنا بانه
وكاننا في اطار يعني
محاكمات او
ذهاب تدريجي من الاخف الى الاكثر ثقلا
والاكثر خطرا بدانا بقضيه اخلاقيه اليوم
نتحدث عن قضيه ولائحه اتهامات عن اخفاء
بعض الملفات التي تخص الامن القومي ولكن
سنتجه كذلك في المستقبل نذكر بانه هناك
انتظار لتحقيق مع ترامب لم يكن هناك طبعا
كلام عن توجيه اتهامات ولكن البعض يترقب
مثل هكذا تحقيقات خاصه باحداث الكابيتال
وهي يقول عنها البعض بانه هددت الامن
الداخلي الامريكي هل هناك نسق متصاعد
يطمح البعض من خلاله ايقاف ترامب عن
الترشح
وهو كذلك يعني انها كاراجمت صواريخ
قانونيه عدليه تهبط على ترامب الواحده بعد
الاخرى كما تفضلتم على هذا البانيل يعني
كان هنالك قبل نيويورك ملفات شخصيه
ومنذ نيويورك هي ملفات سياسيه تتعاظم
مرورا بما نراه الان على هذه الشاشه وهو
فعلا تاريخي ولكن قد يكون هنالك فعلا ملفا
اخر وهو حوادث يناير في عام 2021 ولكن انا
ساكون دقيقا هنا هكذا ملف سياسي يعني
قد يذهب بكل الاتجاهات لانه محاميه ترامب
في هذه في هكذا وضع يبداون بالطلب
بايميلات الطرف الاخر يعني في الحكم
العدلي المحاكمه العدليه ليست من طرف واحد
هي ايضا وكثير من الامور التي اتهم بها
ترامب هي تكهنات وهي مع العلم بانه الذين
هجموا هند هم من انصارهم ولكن هم من
الجناح اليمين المتطرف لانصاري سوف يطلبون
ما هي العلاقه العمليه العمانيه ايميلات
بين مكتب ترامب او هو شخصيا وقاده هؤلاء
من اليمين المتطرف هذا الامر كله سوف يبدا
ولكن اعود واكرر
لن يكون لصالح من يعتقد انه هذه الدعاوى
سوف تمنعه نتائج هذه الدعاوى سوف تظهر في
الدبيد في المناقشات مع الاخرين لانه
سياتي من يمثل الديمقراطيين ويقول انت كنت
مسؤولا عن هذه الاحداث كما قالت وزاره
العدل هذا الذي سوف يؤثر عليه هو استعمال
هذا الفودج الذي نراه في
الاتيه في السنه والنصف القادمه
وملفت كذلك في نفس الاطار الذي تحدثنا عنه
منذ قليل عنوانات نيويورك تايمز وفي
الواقع هي رسمت
لمحاكمه ترامب وقالت واكدت بانه سيقلب
الطاوله على الدعاء وسيتحول لضحيه وهذا ما
اشرت له كذلك قليلا دكتور فارس قلت بانه
ليس هناك شيء ثابت ليس هناك يعني في
القانون نتحدث عاده عن دليل قطعي على اثره
يمكن للقاضي ان يحكم ان يتابع هذه القضيه
وان
يجرم المتهم وهنا سؤال دكتور حنا كيف
يتابع الديمقراطيون امكانيه ان يتحول هذا
الملف الى ملف قادر ان يبرز ترامب من جديد
ان يضعه في واجهه او تحت الاضواء من جديد
لكسب المزيد اولا من التعاطف الشعبي وكذلك
حتى يكون اقوى لانه حضرتك تعلم ما لا يقتل
يقوي وهذا قد يقوي ترامب اكثر
هنالك مجموعه كبيره بالحزب الديمقراطي تود
ان ترى ترامب ينجح في انتخابات التمهيديه
في الحزب الجمهوري وما يحصل من ان يكون
نفسه كالضحيه وتعاطف الحزب الجمهوري معه
وهو ما نراه موجودا بالوقت الحالي حيث
بالوقت الحالي شعبيه
وتدفق الاموال الى حملته الانتخابيه موجود
بشكل كبير وهو يقوم بعمل عمل
رهيب بالاعلام حيث يصور حاله الضحيه يكسب
تعاطف مجموعه كبيره من الجمهوريين وهو شيء
مجموعه كبيره في الحزب الديمقراطي يرونه
شيء ايجابي للديمقراطيين في الانتخابات
العامه حيث التوجه موجود ان اذا كانت
ترامبو هو مرشح الحزب الجمهوري سوف يتمكن
الرئيس بايدن من هزيمته بشكل اسهل لان
التعاطف من قبل المستقلين او القاعده
الوسطيه سوف يكون اكثر مع الحزب
الديمقراطي خصوصا اذا كان الديبيت في
الحزب الجمهوري دي بيت قوي جدا ضد ترامب
وهو ما نلاحظ انه سوف يحصل معظم المرشحين
الان يقومون بالهجوم على الرئيس السابق
ترامب ومن الممكن ان يظهروا مجموعه من
الملفات التي لم تفتح حتى الان خصوصا
بالاحداث التي سبقت وكيفيه التعامل مع
نتائج الانتخابات وهي امور تهم الشعب
الامريكي بشكل كبير
لازالوا لهذه الاونه يعولون على المستقلين
بمعنى انه
الديمقراطيين او الحزب الديمقراطي لم
يتمكن حتى من الاستفاده من كل هذه الملفات
من احداث انشقاقات كبيره يستفاد منها داخل
حزب الجمهوري
هذا كذلك يعتبر فشل سياسي
يتحمله الديمقراطيون
المجتمع الامريكي بشكل عام مقسوم ثلاث
اقسام الجمهوريين والديمقراطيين
والمستقلين وفي الاونه الاخيره نلاحظ نمو
نمو المستقلين على الحزبين كان يعني الحزب
الديمقراطي يريد ان يقوي نفسه داخليا
ويريد ان يجمع حوله داخليا ولكن انتخابات
النصفيه القادمه التي مرقت خسر بها الحزب
الديمقراطي نسبه ولكن نسبه بسيطه جدا
بالنسبه لما يحصل عاده عندما يستلم الرئيس
من الحزب نفسه وحتى الان الديمقراطيين لم
يخسروا حتى بالسند انهم قاموا بفوز بمقعد
واصبح لهم الاغلبيه بالسند فالحزب
الديمقراطي الى الان محافظ على قوته وهو
تتجمع اكثر هنالك بعد التخوف من عمر
الرئيس بايدن وكيف يكون بالحمله
الانتخابيه ولكن حتى الان كل الانظار تتجه
الى المرشح الحزبي الجمهوري
معينه نذكر بانه ترامبي يعني لم يكن له حظ
كبير مع محاميه المحامي السابق هو الذي
فضح بعض الامور المحاميه الحالي اعتقد بان
الادعاء هو الذي فرض عليه ان تسحب منه ما
يعبر عليها بان تكون هناك بعض الامور
السريه ان تسحب من السريه ما يقال له فهل
يمكن الحديث فعليا عن لعنه محاميه ترامب
طبعا في الاعلام والصحافه كما يسمي ترامب
اخصامه باسماء كبيره
وهامه وثقيله الصحافه والاعلام يسمون
ازمات ترامب بالاسماء ومنها لعنه ترامب
هنا ولعنه ترامب هنالك الواقع انه معظم
حياته في القطاع الخاص واين في نيويورك
مدينه الصراع بين المحامين ومحامين
المحامين يعني هذا المحامي الاول الذي
يعني انقلب ضده كان محاميه قبل ذلك على كل
الفئات دكتور فارس اعتقد بان ترامب وصل
البوابه الخارجيه او الاماميه لمحكمه
مايامي فعلا هو وصل موكب ترامب وصل الان
متابع هذا الصور لوصول موكب ترامب يبدو
بانها البوابه الخارجيه لمحكمه ميامي
وهناك سياره شرطه طبعا تؤمن هذا الموكب
ولحظه وصوله هناك مجموعه من الامنيين
توجهوا في بعض او للقي بعض الاجراءات ومن
ثم سيدخل وبدات السيارات تتوجه الى داخل
محيط المحكمه حيث يتواجد عدد كبير وكان
حدثنا منذ قليل مراسله العربيه المتواجد
هناك حسين الطوط متواجد داخل محيط المحكمه
وحدثنا عن حضور اعلامي كبير وعن متابعه
اعلاميه كبيره جدا لحيثيات اولا حيثيات
البدء بالحديث عن هذا الملف وكذلك حتى
التحقيقات والمتابعه السياسيه التصريحات
اتت من الجمهوريين كما كذلك من
الديمقراطيين ولكن كان ملفت في هذه
الساعات الاخيره
صمت الجمهوريين او على الاقل حتى ان لم
يتقدموا بالدعم والتشجيع ومحاوله مؤازره
الرئيس سبقت دونالد ترامب هناك من صمت ولم
يعلق على خاصه لائحه الاتهامات التي تتعلق
بالامن القومي الامريكي
نتحدث عن الاسلحه النوويه الامريكيه نتحدث
عن التمركز العسكري حال الهجوم الخارجي
نتحدث كذلك عن بعض الاسرار الخاصه ببعض
الدول كايران
والصين والعديد من الملفات الاخرى وخاصه
المعلومات الاخرى التي صنفت حساسه وسريه
وبعضها صنف كذلك سري للغايه الان ترامب
لا ليست راب هناك مجموعه من الامنيين
ينزلون من هذه السيارات سنبقى مع هذا
الصور دكتور وليد قطعتك اسمح لي تفضل اكمل
فكرتك ونتابع هذا الصور يمكن ان يعني
في اي لحظه اذا ما نزلت راب من السياره
وتوجه الى بوابه محكمه مايا تفضل دكتور
وليد
دون شك نقاط ستكون سريعه الاولى الذي يجب
ان تبقى في ذهننا في هذه المحاكمات عندما
تبدا هذه المحاكمات لانه ما نراها الان هو
استدعاء ترامب للمحكمه وسؤاله هل تعتقد
بانك يعني فعلا ارتكبت ام لا سيقول لا
وبعد ذلك تبدا المحاكمه الاهم في المحاكمه
في قضائنا هنا ونحن نعلم ذلك هو المحلفين
في النهايه المطاف قد يقوم الاسهام باجمل
الهجوم وتثبيت وياتي الوضع الى المتهمين
حلفين عذرا المحلفين الجوروز ويردون هذه
يريدون هذا الملف لذلك يسعى ترامب ومحامنه
الى الى الاسراع في تغيير الصوره
الاعلاميه لانه ذلك يؤثر على المحلفين
النقطه الثانيه المهمه جدا هنالك سباق
ربما اليوم لن نتكلم عنه للموضوع على
ترامب هو سباق بموضوعان الاول صحه الرئيس
الحالي يعني لقد رايناها جميعا والجميع
يعترف ويعرف انه هذه الصحه الذهنيه وغيره
على تراجع بسيط اثنين هنالك بالطبع
الانقسام يعني هنالك الانقسام في الراي
العام فيما يتعلق بمن سوف يرتكب بنظر
الجمهور الجريمه الاكبر هل ماذا يتهم به
ترامب او الملفات الاتيه الى الرئيس يعني
الاتهامات بانه عندما كان نائب الرئيس قبض
من هذه الجهه والجهه الاخرى وابنه ولما
هنالك يعني تلك الملفات لم تفتح بعد على
الراي العام اذا لننتظر بدعه اشهر فنرى
هذا السباق بين الملفات التي تضرب ترامب
وتضرب اخصامه ايضا ونرى ربما يعني بايلول
وصاعدا من هو الاضعف او المستضعف من هذه
الملف وكاننا في الواقع امام دراما معقده
وحساسه ولكن هي ليست دراما بقدر ما هي
واقع يعيش داخل الامريكي ونعيشه كذلك نحن
نتابعه بكل تفاصيله هي سابقه في تاريخ
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بان يحاكم او
على الاقل بان توجه اللائحه التهامات
فيدراليه الى رئيس سابق نحن دائما
مشاهدينا مع هذا الصور دكتور حنا اليوم
كانت هناك تصريحات
لوزير العدل السابق واليانبار والذي تحدث
في الواقع الى شبكه فوكس نيوز وكانت هناك
تعلم حضرتك بان الاعلام الامريكي فتح
ذراعيه لكل تصريحات لمحاوله
فهمهار يقول بان هذه القضيه هي قضيه تبدو
سهله وهذه قضيه مضمونه النجاح هل تتفق معه
او بالعكس تختلف معه وبالتالي تتفق مع
الدكتور فارس بانه ليس هناك دليل قاطع حتى
الان ودين ترامب
بالحقيقه القضيه وتاخذ بعدين البعد
السياسي والبعد للعدلي او البعد القضائي
البعد القضائي سوف يتم البث فيه لاحقا في
الحقيقه لست مبطلا بشكل كبير جدا على
المعلومات القضائيه وهنالك عده امور لا
نعرفها حتى الان بالنسبه للبعد القضائي
براي سوف ياخذ البعد القضائي وقتا طويلا
جدا
القاضي الموجوده هي تقييم من قبل الرئيس
ترامب وهي تتحكم بشكل كبير ببرنامج
المحكمه فسوف يكون بامكانها تحديد عده
مواعيد بالنسبه لما تراه هي مناسبا ولكن
هذه القضيه ويرحلنا فقط لنشير ثلاث سنوات
لديكم ثقه تامه فيها نحن طبعا نتحدث عما
يروج عن نزاهه القضاء في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
القضاء بشكل عام بالولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هنالك نزاهه ولكن هذه القاضيه
بامكانها ان تتحكم بعده امور تبدو صغيره
بكون تبدو امور انها صغيره ولكن في
الحقيقه هي جوهريه جدا حيث انها تستطيع ان
تتحكم بالاوقات المحكمه وهي من الناحيه
السياسيه سوف تكون مهمه جدا لانها
تشير الى انها قادره ان تتحكم بها لص
الح من الممكن جدا بالنسبه
يا دكتور حنا يعني تقول من جهه بانه
القضاء النازيه هو من جهه اخرى بانها
قادره على التلاعب ببعض الجزئيات
يعني خليني اوضحها بطريقه اكبر هي قاضيه
ولكن هنالك بعض الامور التي تستطيع ان
تتحكم بها وهنالك بعض الامور التي يجب ان
تلتزم بها بالنسبه الى القوانين الموجوده
ومن ضمن الامور التي تستطيع ان تتحكم بها
هي مواعيد الجلسات وكمول الجلسات هذه
الامور تستطيع ان تتحكم بها بشكل قانوني
ايضا بالنسبه
يعني يمكن ان تتحكم مثلا في المدد الزمنيه
ولكن دون خلق القانون ولكن هذا الموضوع
قادر ان يساعد ترامب
ميه بالميه صحيح بامكانها تتحكم بهذه
الامور بشكل قانوني وهي من صلاحياتها ايضا
حيث هذه صلاحيات موجوده لها وبالتالي من
الممكن ان تحددها باوقات تساعد ترامب ايضا
بالنسبه الى اختيار المحلفين في حاله
وصلنا لهذه المرحله فيوجد لها كلمه في هذا
الموضوع وهو موضوع رئيسي جدا كما اسلت
الدكتور لانه اختيار المحلفين سوف يؤثر
بشكل رئيسي على النتائج المحكمه
اشير الى هذا الصور المباشره لحضور انصار
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب هم حاضرون
يهتفون يرفعون شعارات منذ قليل كنا
استمعنا لهم كذلك بصوت الطبيعي تحدثوا عن
ان هذا الملف هو ملف سياسي بالاساس هناك
محاوله للتجني على الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب وهناك ذلك الى جانب
حضور انصار ترامب هناك حضور اعلامي كبير
وضخم جدا في محيط محكمه ميامي ضيوفي
الكرام اشكركم جزيل الشكر ساكتفي معكم
بهذا القدر ولكن ابقوا متابعين لشاشه
العربيه لاننا سنبقى في متابعه كل هذه
التطورات لحظه بلحظه من واشنطن دكتور وليد
فارس الخبير في السياسه الخارجيه
الامريكيه ومن واشنطن ايضا الدكتور حنا
حنان يا ممثل الحزب الديمقراطي في ولايه
فرجينيا شكرا جزيلا لكم على المشاركه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والو وتقارير الاخباريه
لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات